so the big question tonight where does
it all go from here well joining us now
with analysis the author of
the price of principal harvard law
professor alan dershowitz
along with former u.s attorney brett
tolman and fox news legal analyst greg
jarrett gentlemen thank you for joining
us
brett your former u.s attorney i want to
start with you because i just can't get
past the fact that a judge less than two
months ago had to recuse themselves
we don't know exactly why but had to
recuse himself from a trump issue and
then
less than two months later he's making
this ruling i just don't get how that
happens in today's legal system
jason if the recusal came as a result of
the political connection between this
judge and hillary clinton which it most
likely was then it really really is
outrageous that he would not again
recuse himself when the main political
adversary of hillary clinton obama biden
anyone on the left is
former president donald trump you would
have thought that it would have applied
also in this circumstance especially in
the criminal law when there's a lot more
on the line
and craig um i love the piece you wrote
on foxnews.com but essentially they were
given a fishing license to to go to town
there on donald trump's residence what's
your read of what you read there in the
affidavit
well this is what i read
there are 20 pages of this out of a
total of 30.
so you know you'll recall that mira
garland stood in front of cameras and
microphones and said we will speak
through our filings well this is how he
speaks he muzzled
his voice
with black ink he probably ran through
two or three sharpie pens to do all 20
pages of this
the first eight pages we actually get to
see but that's simply a recitation by
rote of
legal statutory quotations and
vague background information
but you do learn two things two mistakes
by the fbi merrick garland first of all
they assume
uh that all of these documents they want
or some of them at least are classified
without ever considering that trump may
have declassified them their second
mistake is they automatically assume
that these three statutes criminal
statutes general statutes that they cite
as authority that gives them probable
cause to go into trump's home
is the controlling law they never
considered that it's not the controlling
laws of the presidential
records act uh it is a specific statute
that takes precedent over
the general statutes and it does give a
former president a measure and a right
of control and custody access and
possession but they never considered
that
and neither by the way did the
magistrate when he signed off on
this now professor dershowitz uh you've
seen a lot of cases in your time what do
you make of this this situation
well i disagree with your two previous
speakers reinhardt did the right thing
by
signing the search warrant
every single judge and magistrate in the
united states would have found probable
cause based on this affidavit they may
have narrowed the search somewhat but
there is absolutely no doubt there was
probable cause that's number one number
two
the real
professor hold on a second professor
hold on a second again i want to ask you
a question there
sure the judge recused himself less than
two months later on a case on donald
trump how does he turn around and goes
and says yeah i can make a ruling on
this
every judge would have made the same
ruling so it's no harm no foul the
problem was not with reinhardt it was
with the attorney general who didn't
follow his own
guidelines there should never have been
a search warrant requested here there
was a subpoena issued and what i read
and i read it all
of the unredacted material makes a
strong case against a search warrant
there was no urgency if they wanted a
search warrant if it was so urgent they
could have gotten it five months ago and
even when they got the search warrant
they waited two days there was no
justification for a search warrant so if
you want to talk about who's to blame
here it's not reinhardt it's the
attorney general of the united states he
should never have sought a search
warrant the other important thing is
there is enough evidence here to indict
trump but trump will not be indicted in
my view because the evidence doesn't
pass what i call the nixon clinton
standards the nixon standard is the case
has to be so overwhelmingly strong that
even republicans support it and the
clinton standard is why is this case
more serious than clinton's case where
there wasn't a criminal prosecution so i
think the three points are there was
probable cause they shouldn't have
sought a warrant there is enough for an
indictment but there will not be an
indictment and should not be an
indictment based on what we've seen up
to now once it's unredacted maybe we'll
have to change our minds
what's your reaction
would have taken a look at this thing
and they asked challenging questions and
would have said wait a minute
the controlling statute here's the
presidential records act why aren't you
seeking an enforcement proceeding here
to get the documents that you want
that's what a good judge would have done
i i think
the judge would have seen through this
charade
yeah
no hold on hold on let's let brett
respond to this
brett your what's your date there's
probably
if there's probable cause in this uh
this affidavit it's it's in the redacted
parts because the and redacted parts do
not have probable cause in them it's not
sufficient for for based on what we know
in order to justify the search warrant
i agree with the professor that a search
warrant was not justified in this case
both because we don't have the probable
cause necessary to issue it but also
because
the very things that are outlined in the
unredacted part
explicitly indicate a back and forth
dialogue it reads more like a civil
you know a civil dispute and let me tell
you jason if you have to take 38 pages
to try to convince a judge that there's
probable cause you may have a problem
with your case the problem causes an
extremely low standard warrants are
given out like christmas gifts
this judge did a much better job than
most did most judges would not have
issued the affidavit even with
redactions uh this judge had no choice i
don't believe there's a judge in the
country who would not have issued a
search warrant yeah some of them may
have asked them hard questions but the
judge's job is different from the
attorney general the judge has to look
at the evidence that's in the affidavit
and make a legal decision the attorney
general has to make a
discretionary decision and he has to
abide by justice department standards so
if you're going to point the finger in
anybody here point it at garland not at
reinhardt that's my view i think they
had enough to get probable cause but
they shouldn't have sought a warrant in
the first place and if they did seek a
warrant it should have been narrower
there's no justification for searching
the closet of mrs trump or even for
going into the safe i didn't see any
cause for that but general probable
cause i didn't exist
greg greg why why why didn't this judge
take a look at the warrant itself and
say wait a minute this is a general
search warrant that's a direct violation
of the fourth amendment to the
constitution which requires specificity
particularly described documents to be
seized at particular locations none of
that is in this warrant so a good judge
would have seen through this sham and
would have said wait a minute i'm not
going to sign off on something like this
it's a violation of the target's
constitutional rights
bret what's your reaction to that
this is not a normal case this is not a
standard case it's one in which
the president clearly can possess
classified documents the president also
has the unfettered ability the supreme
court tells us in navy v eagan that he
can
declassify documents and so without the
judge being informed properly of that
you don't have a basis in judge
reinhardt's position to understand
whether or not you truly have a statute
that applies in this circumstance so so
the professor may be accurate but we
don't know yet we don't know whether or
not there was probably
the rest of that
portion
professor hold on i'm going to give you
the last word here but i i want you to
keep in mind that a president of the
united states always in perpetuity has
the highest classification that is
possible and to suggest that they're not
in a secure to suggest that they're not
in a secure situation when they're
protected by the secret service for
goodness sake uh it's hardly a case to
be made that they're out there floating
uh out out there in the public and pose
a grave danger and i i do agree with you
the idea that they didn't act
immediately if there was such urgency
that why we're 19 months after donald
trump left office that now they're just
dealing this does not lend to their
credibility right before we go into the
med terms i agree with all that but
there was probable cause even without
the classification issue remember to get
probable cause all you have to show
is that there is a probability that you
can find evidence of some crime and the
crime specified in the war we're not
provide materials but they included
kinds of things that hillary clinton was
charged with now she was not subjected
to a search warrant thus the double
standard so i want to make a sharp
distinction between what the judge
did and should have done i agree with
you we should have narrowed the search
warrant should have asked some hard
questions but there was probable cause
but there was not enough urgency for the
attorney general to violate the
standards of the justice department
particularly against a future
presidential candidate who was running
against the president who appointed the
attorney general in that situation you
have to be extra careful to make sure
justice is not only done but it's seen
to be done and this does not satisfy
that standard
and this now gentlemen you're getting to
the heart of the nub we got to move on
uh and i want to thank the three of you
but this gets right to it because you
know what when i was the chairman of the
oversight committee and i issued
subpoenas and hillary clinton took beat
bleach bit and destroyed documents when
we issued subpoenas on the irs for
documents on political targeting and
they destroyed documents when we had
these types of situations guess what the
department of justice didn't go in their
guns ablazing with with with uh
documents to go seize things they handed
out immunity agreements to those people
that's the rub it's the unequal
application of justice that makes this
totally and fundamentally a targeting
situation and it's not right and until
lady justice acts the same with a biden
and a clinton as it does with the trump
or anybody in between we're going to
continue to have a problem in this
country i i got to move on i went
overtime greg brett and professor
professor dershowitz i really do thank
you for joining us tonight on hannity
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else